I just want to start with the sincere
congratulations uh the movie's fantastic
uh before I have a lot of questions but
before we jump into it Chris I just have
to ask you when do I get to see pool man
man I you know I want to show Pullman
off I don't know firstly I have to sell
the film I have to find someone who
wants to distribute the film so
uh neon uh a24 I'm looking at you
um but soon hopefully soon I love my
film it makes me giggle
and a lot of people seem to giggle and
they watch it and I'm very proud of it
very very proud of it I can't wait to
see that I know I'm going to set up a
screening because it looks like it it's
going to be a wobble for maybe it hits
theaters but I'll set up a screening
invite everyone in the world that's cool
don't be afraid to send one my way now
I'm jumping into why I get to talk to
you guys how happy you guys went around
the world to promote the cost to promote
this movie at Comic-Con you went to
Brazil you've been in San Diego how
happy are you that the movie is awesome
you know I like I like Prestige man I
like great questions yeah
this is coming from a guy with like you
know he's he's got the Back to the
Future Card backdrop he's got
Transformer doll in the backdrop he's
got Charlie Brown uh
uh certainly sucks when a movie sucks
um this one doesn't fall into that
category thank God what was really fun I
have to say is going this out by
Southwest I had never been to that
Paramount Theater in that Paramount
Theater is such an incredible venue
because it's so small it's so tight it's
so cavernous that there's like no chance
for any energy to dissipate and this
film is specifically made
you know this is made for audience it's
made for film goers it's made to be seen
in the theater it's made to be shared so
to be able to be in that
um in that environment to feel the
energy go around to feel people laugh to
gasp to cry to all of it was really
really exciting one of the things about
the film well one of the many things
that it's really funny the action is
well staged and um you care about the
characters uh so I'm just curious for
this was not the question I was gonna I
was going with but I'm very for both of
you what are you actually most excited
for people to see because there's so
many good things in this movie for me
it's the fact that there are a lot of
practical effects in it so that a lot of
it to me feels like films that I grew up
watching like uh Goonies or uh I don't
know really anything Willow Princess
Bride there's a lot of real in this and
I think in an age of so much commuter
graphics and certainly we have a bunch
of that in this there are a lot of
scenes that employ practical
old-fashioned craftsmanship
um animatronics and and and stuff that
you know we haven't really seen on film
in a long time and I think that's really
exciting yeah I'm with him on that you
know to be fair like it's just so
awesome you know Legacy did such a
wonderful job you know creating all of
these creatures and I think that their
debut is everything to me
um and it's you can just tell the
difference I mean I I can't put my
finger on it but I could tell the
difference between you know it's a
mixture between digital and animatronic
but you could see that there is a
three-dimensional you know robotic
movement behind all of it and I think
that there's something really cool about
that I don't know I think the creatures
it's just all about the creatures for me
and I just can't wait for all the the
the the Easter eggs to kind of like
shine through I have to wrap with you
already I'm just gonna say sincere
congrats and I really do want this to be
a big hit so you guys can do more so
thank you that's all she saw